the American woman linked to her car
crash that killed a British teenager now
says she is willing to meet with the
victim's family police say that ants
akula's killed 19 year old Harry Dunne
in August after she was driving on the
wrong side of the road in the UK
cyclists who was reportedly married to a
u.s. intelligence officer was granted
diplomatic immunity after the crash and
flew back to the United States
now that immunity has been called into
question MT as taya has been following
the story from the very beginning I
guess first question is what's the
status of the immunity yeah a lot of
fast-moving developments in this story
gale and what I can tell you is
britain's Foreign Secretary has sent a
letter to Dunn's parents saying the UK
government's position is that immunity
is no longer relevant that we've reached
out to the State Department to confirm
if that means and cyclists no longer has
immunity or can be extradited and are
still waiting on an answer now seven
weeks after Harry's death the family has
now heard from and soukous in a
statement from her lawyers and cyclists
said she is devastated that and rather
that the reporting has in her words
being inaccurate and in many respects
that she our rather that has been
inaccurate in many respects now she does
want to meet with Harry Dunn's family
we've gotten to know this family pretty
well over the last few weeks Charlotte
and Tim have gotten to know me we've
traveled with them and they say that
they really want to meet with an
sequoias but they want to meet her back
in the UK they want her to cooperate
with British investigators and really
the most important thing for them is
that cyclists faces the authorities in
the UK because they say no one and their
words should be above the law
it's also another very complicated story
can we say nice to have you at the table
sorry it's under these circumstances
nice to meet you in person MTS thank you